i wanted to create a short video on the six things
that men should not be eating all these things
increase estrogen and shut down your testosterone
and that's not good because it can affect your
your muscle density your overall endurance
your energy your vitality it can trigger
erectile dysfunction a decreased libido it
can put on weight it can create man boobs
and the list goes on and on and on all
right number one flax now check this out
flax this is a phytoestrogen okay it has way more
estrogen than even soy and soy is high in estrogen
so flax is a no-no for men the only
situation i would recommend flax
for females is if they actually have low estrogen
so flax is something you want to avoid flax seed
anything connected to flax flax oil and then
avoid soy and that includes soy protein isolates
that can also increase estrogen all right next one
glyphosate and atrazine these are two herbicides
the first one is involved in gmo the second one
is just a chemical that they spray on our foods
both of these increase estrogen and so the
solution for that is to do organic foods
next one is red dyes red dye has the
capacity to increase estrogen pretty
significantly now if you're doing my version of
the ketogenic diet which is the healthy version
chances are you're not going to consume
any red dyes so i just recommend
you do my version of the ketogenic diet i put a
link down below but red dyes not good tap water
especially if you live in the southern part of the
united states tap water has significant amounts of
estrogen as well as other bad things as well so
you want to get a filter to get that filtered out
i mean you just don't want to drink any tap water
this not just estrogen there's a lot of other
chemicals and the thing about water is that most
people drink a good amount of water in a given day
so if you're you're drinking a lot of tap water
getting all that estrogen that could be the reason
why you may have low testosterone right there
okay milk and milk products i'm not saying to
avoid it completely make sure that if you consume
it it's from grass-fed cows make sure it's non-gmo
preferably organic and do smaller amounts now i'm
not recommending milk but i'm talking about cheese
so just make sure you don't overdo it with the
cheese especially if you want to maintain your
healthy testosterone levels hey before you go real
quick i have a course entitled how to bulletproof
your immune system it's a free course i want
you to take it and here's why here's you
here is your environment
everyone is focused on this over
here avoiding your environment but
what about here what about strengthening
your immune system that's what's missing
this course will show you how to bulletproof
yourself and so you can tolerate and resist
your environment much better by strengthening
your own immune system i put a link down
in the description right down below
check it out and get signed up today